Salut les amis !
Bienvenue dans Team Foufou, New Life.
Vous avez un problème ?
Nous trouvons la solution.
Voici Régis.
Régis a du mal à trouver un job.
En effet, il n'est pas assez sûr de lui et a du mal à s'exprimer en public.
Objectif : faire de Régis le pro des entretiens d'embauche.
C'est parti !
Régis...
Bienvenue dans notre QG.
C'est ici que la magie va opérer.
Ouais, ça, c'est grand.
En un coup d'oeil, on se rend vite compte que tu n'es pas prêt à passer des entretiens.
Ah ok.
Mais sais-tu ce qu'il faut pour passer un entretien ?
Je dirais, avant toute chose, un CV démontrant toutes les capacités...
Négatif.
Ce qu'il te faut ? C'est ce petit truc en plus.
Et Jeff va s'occuper de te montrer. Let's go !
C'est... C'est là-bas ? Ouais.
Ok.
Regarde mon gars !
Est-ce que ça t'épate ?
Ouais...
Ici, t'as tout un tas d'éléments qui te permettront de décrocher un job.
Mais seul l'un d'entre eux fera de toi un as des entretiens.
Let's go ! C'est à toi mon gars !
Ouais !
Non, non, non.
Non, non.
Ouais, non...
C'est ringard.
Tu vas vite le sentir à l'instinct, ce truc.
Ah tu me fais une blague, là !
Bah oui...
Evidemment...
Reste focus...
Est-ce que tu te sens prêt à passer un entretien ?
Ouais.
Voilà !
Attention les recruteurs !
Il arrive sur le marché !
Ah c'est un loup !
Pas si vite Jeff !
Ce n'est pas encore suffisant pour garantir de la réussite à un entretien.
Dustin va s'occuper d'améliorer ça...
Ok, Régis.
Ton apparence ? C'est bon.
Maintenant, il faut que tu aies plus d'assurance quand tu parles en public.
C'est vrai que j'ai un peu... de manque de confiance en moi... Je te le confirme.
C'est maintenant comment tu penses qu'on peut y parvenir...
En travaillant mon élocution de façon assez... Pas du tout !
En insultant... nos mères !
Ok.
Régis, ta mère, elle est tellement grosse...
Qu'elle est incapable d'applaudir !
1000 kilos la meuf !
Ça, c'est des idées reçues sur le... le poids ou...
Surtout, te laisse pas faire Régis.
Allez !
Bah toi, elle a quel âge ta mère ?
Hein ? T'oses pas répondre !
Elle a quoi ? Elle a...
Hein ?
400... 400 ans ou quoi !
C'est pas mal, ça, Régis.
Toi, ta mère, elle est tellement feignasse...
Qu'elle a une télécommande...
Pour sa télécommande !
Ok.
Ouais bah toi, ta mère... Elle est tellement conne... que quand elle appelle quelqu'un...
Et que le correspondant, en ligne, n'entend pas...
Elle dit: " Allô ?"
"Allô ?"
"Je vais défitiv... définitivement changer d'opérateur..."
Je pense que Régis a besoin d'un peu d'encouragement. Allez !
Régis ! Régis ! Régis !
Ta mère, c'est une grosse pute.
Si c'est pas un synonyme de confiance en soi !
Régis ! Régis ! Régis !
Ok, les amis ! La mission de la Team Foufou s'arrête ici.
Régis a maintenant tout ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir passer son entretient.
Merci les omis...
Grâce à vous, il y a aucune chance que j'échoue !
Allez !
Défonce tout mec !
Let's go !
Et nous, on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour aider Solange...
Qui a du mal à oublier son petit copain...
Du nom de Carl !
Carl !?
Avec un nom aussi naze, moi aussi j'aurai certainement du mal à l'oublier !
Pauvre Carl !